obesity is a Public Health crisis in
many countries and also a private
struggle for a lot of people this is the
first category of drugs that we have
seen that may be able to make a dent in
this problem every year science chooses
what we anoint as a breakthrough of the
year it's essentially a development in
the world of science that we assess as
being particularly exciting
groundbreaking this year we selected
what are known as glp1 receptor Agonist
drugs these are a class of drugs that
are being used very successfully to
treat type 2 diabetes and especially
obesity this year in particular what got
us especially excited is that the drugs
also have been shown to reduce the risk
of some health problems that are associ
iated with obesity like heart attacks
strokes and the symptoms of heart
failure gp1 stands for glucagon like
peptide 1 gp1 is what's called an
incretin hormone and that's a category
of hormones that are secreted by the gut
and that then trigger this release of
insulin when this was first discovered
scientists thought hey you know maybe we
can somehow harness this and give it as
a treatment to people with diabetes
at the time there was only one other
known member of that category called Gip
and Gip had been tried to see if it
could treat people with diabetes and it
didn't work we were very very much
surprised when we found out that uh glp1
in advanced stages of type 2 diabetes
was able to substantially stimulate
insulin
secretion what we did not foresee at
that time was the whole uh story about
weight loss in the '90s there were
various sort of threads of discoveries
that brought appetite and obesity into
the
picture while giving people glp1 could
have these very intriguing effects it
wasn't practical as a drug right away
and that was because if you gave someone
glp1 it disappeared from their body
within minute the first glp1 receptor
Agonist that was approved was a product
of
serendipity it was isolated from the
saliva of a lizard living in
Arizona by chance exenatide had a
halflife of 2 to three hours so after a
single injection you would cover the
period that a body needs to digest a
meal now we have agents that you can
inject once a
week as soon as people started clinical
trials with gp1 receptor Agonist it was
noted that patients would lose some
weight what we've learned over the years
is that there are receptors for gp1 that
are in the pancreas and they're also in
the brain and the brain is very
important as a center for helping
control hunger and that sensation of
feeling full many of our patients report
that their relationship with food is so
much different and there's less of this
kind of propensity to think about food
in a way that may be distressing to them
no drug is perfect so it's important to
to mention that there's still our side
effects but certainly these do not seem
to have the very very serious safety
problems that some of the past obesity
drugs have had many people who've lived
with obesity for years have been told
many times by health Care Professionals
to lose weight but really they're not
given effective tools to do so when they
go to seek help for their weight they
may be told something that's not
evidence-based that may at best help
them to decrease their weight maybe 3 to
5% but really to see meaningful changes
in health outcomes we're talking about a
minimum of 10% weight reduction an
ideally 15 20 or even greater body
weight reduction the first jp1 agent for
treating obesity we see about 8 to 9%
weight reduction with lorag with the
Advent of stide we've seen an average
weight reduction in people without
diabetes of around
15% but there's a lot of physiology that
goes into obesity that will resist
people staying in that lower body weight
State and it will really support weight
regain from the data we have so far it
does look like if you go off of the
drugs you have a good chance of of
regaining at least a decent portion of
the weight lost obesity is a chronic
disease and needs chronic therapy
there's a lot of weight bias in society
where people still believe that obesity
is a result of being inconsistent or
even being lazy and I think that's
really harmful when what we're doing is
we're trying to treat a disease and make
sure that we avoid
complications there was a study that
came out in the summer looking at people
who had heart failure and obesity the
people who got
stide had a reduction in their symptoms
of heart failure they were able to walk
farther on a kind of standard walking
test there's a trial that ended early
this year that was looking at people
with diabetes and kidney disease which
is a not uncommon complication of
diabetes and found a benefit there
beyond the Obesity treatment scientists
are looking at drug addiction alcoholism
cigarette smoking and that's a real area
of Interest we don't know yet how that's
going to pan
out in medicine there's always another
chapter can we do better can we do more
what drug companies started to do is
design drugs that mimic gp1 but also
Target in some way another hormone or
other hormones one of the obvious
combinations is gp1 plus Gip because
they are the hormones who act in concert
to regulate insulin secretion after
meals the first one that really made it
to clinical trials was
tepati tepati is much better in terms of
effect sizes both for glycemic control
and body weight reduction if you compare
it to the most potent selective glp1
receptor
agonists right now the glp1 receptor
Agonist drugs are approved and generally
available in the US and several European
countries they're expensive and so a lot
of countries are thinking in terms of
the population health benefit is the the
benefit going to be worth the cost it's
really important for us to look at this
not as just a journey to help people to
lose weight but as a journey to help
people to achieve Better
[Music]
Health